the other thing I want to play if you
can play James Comey here he was being
interviewed this week and the questions
being asked and by the way this is a guy
that loved being interviewed a lot came
out he was everywhere right Comey Comey
Comey and then all of a sudden he's
disappeared a little bit you know and
but uh this was a interview that was
done what is this like a few days ago a
couple days ago I don't know what the
exact date on this is it's not too too
uh uh this could have been a couple days
ago if you just play it see what he says
here really honest honest loving guy too
yeah so much people in law enforcement
which matters so as for the Durham
report 300 Pages four years
investigating the investigators one of
the things that did come out of it was
that procedures regular FBI procedures
were ignored that the steps were missed
along the way in this investigation in
fact director Ray said when the report
came out yeah we acknowledged that a
couple of years ago and we've changed
all that those changes are already in
place do you acknowledge perhaps that
some mistakes were made along the way oh
definitely and they were found four
years ago by the Inspector General so
there's nothing new in this new document
what were some of those mistakes from
your point of view oh that the FBI
didn't communicate clearly the status of
certain sources they didn't double check
certain information before putting it in
a court application for foreign
intelligence wiretap and a bunch of
others and so do you believe now as
these some of these politicians call for
defunding of the FBI that that has been
corrected and then now the procedures
are in place to avoid those kind of
mistakes in the future I think so but in
complex investigations there's always
going to be mistakes it doesn't mean the
FBI is incompetent honest and
independent so director
honest incompetent and independent this
is your former boss how do you feel
about what your former boss is saying
here he's doing the same thing that uh
that the FBI did after the initial
release of the Durham before that
moveon.org move where this is old news
this is already addressed four years ago
we can't tell you how we did it but but
we did it and again back to his college
of cardinals mindset of on beyond all
ethical reproach or questioning in
anything that there's no personal
accountability there he never says yeah
I messed up he never takes uh any sort
of responsibility for something thing
like I'm going to direct agents to go
and talk to Mike Flynn because I hope
that he lacks Candor and we can charge
him with a process crime and I'm gonna
brag about it openly isn't that the
player's code you know like guys you
know uh when you're a player and you
have a lot of girlfriends and you're
coming up you know the code is you can
never say you did anything wrong you
didn't do this so if James Comey was a
guy that he shows a lot of signs of a
player you know Playboy type of a guy
yeah so he I feel like he listens to a
lot of r b and Hip-Hop he just kind of
seems like that kind of a guy but going
back to it so for him yeah it's not a
big deal so you know it's it's not not a
big deal we've addressed that we've
gotten better it's cool is it is it the
mindset of never ever admit and just
kind of be casual and cool about it and
move on
or is it more a you know cultural thing
of the FBI or just him that's doing this
I think it's the culture of the FBI and
he just embodied it I mean you just you
the reputation for the FBI is everything
to it protect The Shield at all cost
when uh when I was accused of making
this recording of my meeting with my
asacs which I did I was asked about it
in in my interview my compelled
interview which I was not allowed to
have an attorney actually assist me with
just sit there and watch they tried to
get me to lack Candor so they could
charge me and do a search warrant and
arrest me
um I had said yes I created that the
natural follow-up for anybody and these
are FBI agents who are who are asking me
these questions is can we get a copy of
that because I was making some rather
huge uh Revelations to them that I was
being possibly compelled to do something
that I felt was a civil rights violation
they never asked for a copy which means
they have a copy as I suspected my asex
recorded the conversation as well and
they were not worried about what they
those guys told me they were just
worried about the exposure
reputation is everything
can you look at the uh Yelp to see what
their online reviews are for FBI like
how many positive reviews
that's got to be a joke I was actually
just joking can you read the reviews go
to the bottom tell me this is a joke
this has to be a joke right my family
and I were given a 20 oh it's a tour
thing experience okay go down is it
actually FBI some of the FBI needs to go
race should be the first I had no clue
there by the way if you have bad
experience with the FBI go writer Yelp
reviews
there's no chance go little Lord this is
actually comical now I couldn't even
believe it five stars so I have a
confession my dream job even now is to
work for the Affairs of Fielding it
seems so exciting fun and interesting
saving the world and fighting crime this
is what 2016 with a lot has changed
since then miss Maggie C so go a little
Lord Jerry Lee okay keep going keep
going keep going uh uh so is this one
walking past the back end building I
turned to my husband and said I bet this
is the FBI headquarters I feel like I'm
an episode of The X-Files lo and behold
lo and behold when we reached the front
it was I wish we could have gone inside
but it looked like a closed not sure if
it was a secret thing it was over there
perhaps it was even open like Wally
World from National Lampoon I'd love to
see what Trump left as a review of the
FBI so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign